alors que des familles vont se retrouver
à la rue dans quelques jours le
gouvernement legault sort le chéquier on
annonce deux partenariats des
investissements de 395 millions de
dollars pour les logements ce sont 3000
nouveaux logements abordables et sociaux
qui seront rendues disponibles à court
terme et un moyen moyen terme québec va
confier 350 millions au fonds de
solidarité de la ftq et au mouvement
desjardins pour la construction de 2000
logements sociaux et abordables dans un
horizon de trois ans et 45 millions
iront fondaction de la csn pour la
construction de 1000 logements en
copropriété d'ici cinq ans ils seront
vendus en formule coopérative
25% sur le prix du marché
le gouvernement legault affirme que ces
initiatives vont permettre de rattraper
le retard constaté dans la construction
de logements sociaux à son arrivée au
pouvoir avec l' annonce d'aujourd'hui on
va dépasser les 15000 construit là dans
deux trois ans ça c'est certain la 4 n'a
pas livré la marchandise mais le frapru
est déçu du bilan du gouvernement la
promesse électorale c'était de libre et
les quinze mille logements sociaux déjà
prévu dans accès logis au moment où on
se parle c'est à peu près le tiers des
logements qui ont été effectivement
livrées par ailleurs québec et ottawa
pourrait s'entendre d'ici quelques jours
concernant le fonds national de co
investissement pour le logement lundi
radio-canada rapportait que les deux
gouvernements négocient depuis 4h
processus d'octroi des fonds ce qui m'a
enterré la construction et la rénovation
de près de 6000 logements sociaux dans
la métropole nous ce qu'on a négocié
avec la fédéral s'était classé à chelles
octroyait rapidement les montants
maintenant on attend après la schl là
c'est pas nous non une déclaration qui
surprend à ottawa mais il ya absolument
rien qui empêche québec aujourd'hui
d'autoriser le versement de ces fonds
cette question-là doit absolument se
régler le plus rapidement possible au
plus tard avant le début de la campagne
électorale un accord permettrait de
financer une quinzaine de projets à
brève échéance des logements qui sont
loin d'être luxe dans un marché de plus
en plus inabordable
et ce livre des bâches un réseau canada
montréal